c'est une constante à chaque crise
mondiale ne cours de l'or s'envole
l'or est ce qu'on appelle une valeur
refuge dans l'économie est incertaine
c'est un investissement stable
une façon de mettre son argent à l'abri
des gens s'en vont véritablement avec
leur langue dans la poche dans la poche
c'est ça oui premier exemple les années
70 et 80 période marquée par les deux
chocs pétroliers
plus qu'ailleurs dans le monde les
français se sont rués vers l'or en 1975
ils ont possédé 4600 tonnes au total et
on a toujours hors période de crise les
français investissent ailleurs
l'immobilier l'assurance vie sont
préférés alors car plus rentable mais
quand les bourses mondiales s'affole le
réflexe revient en france et dans tous
les pays développés
l'exemple même dès le début de la
dernière grande crise financière
mondiale en 2008 de nombreux français se
précipiter au comptoir de vente
quelqu'un soir là la polémique lors il y
a ceux qui achetaient de l'or pour
mettre leur argent à l'abri
en revanche pour ceux qui en possédait
déjà c'est l'occasion de le revendre au
plus haut prix dans ces moments troublés
je ne suis pas acheteur de chine vendeur
avant en 2011 l'or a atteint une valeur
historique 1900 $ noz après la crise le
cours de l'or a chuté avant de remonter
depuis début 2016 aujourd'hui encore 73%
des français le considèrent comme une
valeur refuge
[Musique]